it was quite the send-off The Terraces
of flag waving school children
traditional Irish music and a stage set
in front of the cathedral that Joe
Biden's ancestor had supplied the bricks
to build and the U.S president whose
irishness deeply influences his
political Outlook
I mean Ireland America runs deep
our history our
our future our friendship our joys
but more than anything hope is what
beats in the hearts of all our people
for Sanctuary even during times of
darkness and despair hope has kept us
marching forward toward a better future
one of Greater Liberty
greater dignity
and greater possibilities
for Ballina Joe Biden is literally a
larger than life figure this mural
completed in three days by a community
group just before his presidential
victory in 2020. I caught up with the
artist who designed it and the rest of
the group who helped make it reality
it was a team effort we were spending
nights there doing it and uh to know
where to go to the lifts and oh God
ladders and you know paint here paint
there but look we got through it and and
the end result is absolutely perfect you
know and so we're all proud of it and
proud to hear that people have been
there there have been disappointments on
this trip Biden's visit to Belfast for
example was reduced to just a few hours
but the enthusiasm of the welcome in
Dublin and Dundalk are now in mayo has
exceeded even the most optimistic
expectations
the end of truly extraordinary three-day
trip by the U.S president a trip which
has combined the personal and the
political Joe Biden has spoken
repeatedly with warmth about the
importance of his Irish ancestry and of
a sense of homecoming and it's a
sentiment which has gone down very well
with the audience here Paul Brennan Al
Jazeera balina